all of us down here in Mission Control
welcome to
Stace the Russians always knocked three
times I think it's just a
[Applause]
Superstition listening to the wind of
wow I mean I seen pictures but this is
we don't talk politics here we are
[Music]
one hey guys wait a minute what the hell
is going on down there wa we got to get
off now guys get out oh my
God
you Cent do you
read War has broken out
below and we were told to take the
ISS by any means necessary if we got
orders from our government to take
[Music]
control what do you suggest we do now
did you
ever
we could be CL the Russians got the same
orders as
us and they just struck first struck
[Music]
first M we're evolved
species
w